[Music]
hey you are you trying to disable boring
reality day in and day out okay you
described this must be a patient
experience alive your favorite risk you
Monique Aragon and cricket morning PR
it's not growing fool what is this Rick
it looks like some sort of creepy video
game about us or something
not just a video game Morty it's a
virtual reality game I told our
likenesses to some video game publisher
for a lot of money Morty and they made
it made a whole virtual reality game and
it's gonna it's got all kinds of great
things about it Morty I don't understand
Rick I mean look I don't know if I like
this you know I don't care if you like
mornings because it's a VR game it's the
hottest new trend Mort it's the hottest
new future of entertainment Morty yeah I
don't know what look at these features
Morty it doesn't get much better than
this 40 well at least this part looks
kind of fun I guess look look at those
heads explode like what okay what else
you actually do in this game you might
be asking yourself what else in this
game had to offer
well we it's got one of these things in
it if you can do this little gimmick
Rick I mean I'm gonna play this you're
gonna play this Morty oh my god you
killed it I mean me I never understand
its majesty VR for everyone everyone
with the Box on their face forty one day
you'll understand Morty Brady Connie
here see our land
Lady Bunny ha ha beloved um
hey youtubers is Charlie so I had a
chance to play the first Rick and Morty
virtual reality game so I uploaded
episode 1 I cut this way down it is full
of Easter eggs if you're a hardcore Rick
& Morty band it's pretty cool Justin
roiland recorded a whole bunch of new
dialogue for this as Rick and Morty so
I'm not going to talk over this but
overall review at the end of the video
so enjoy crap Rick you made a morty
clone Rick yeah I know I had to
rearrange the entire garage to do it
Morty Morty clone pay attention to me I
need you to take this laundry and put it
in the washing machine and if that's too
confusing instructions for you you know
there's a dry erase board on the is I
put up in the garage here the dry erase
board area you'll see I wrote
instructions on what you're supposed to
do
Wow Rick is a regular old Morty clone
okay good so now it's a 40 clone fitting
for laundry I don't need it anymore I
mean it's pretty much just a useless
pile of floating head in hand so I think
I'll just go ahead and shoot looks like
your dad welcome purgatory the devil's
not available so you give me the double
secretary we won't actually expect you
to be dead so soon so if you don't want
me dead you can just press that button
yeah over here Morty clone listen had to
bring you back for some really important
stuff that I can't get into right now
because me and Morty had to go some
stuffs gotten out of hand
yeah you know we've got to hurry Rick
come on alright listen I made a teleport
system for you all you have to do is you
know look in the direction you want to
go in the room and push the a or X
button on your controller just push the
button down and you can teleport to any
part of the room we get an area you want
to go to in the garage like right now
one last thing Morty clone there's a
watch over there on the shelves I'm
going to need you to grab the locks and
put it on your wrist you'll be able to
call me using the watch this is very
important all right Morty clone
when Rick hurry all right Morty clone we
got to go don't touch any of my stuff
while we're gone
Oh oh good you found the watch
you're not dumb as I thought we can use
that to call me back once you get the
lay of the land
you know what job with those you think
they want appear in the same place with
you we can't have your matter
intersecting with their matter in the
same time and space you know kind of
Timecop situation I modified the meaning
that you can't leave the garage they
should mimic every action you do except
for teleporting shores I'm going to call
them I love that game so much I tried to
find a home version of it they ended up
finding a cramping knockoff and some
weird con shop probably made in a
foreign country no offense the
foreigners got to be real PC around here
this is a VR gamer in a very
forward-thinking environment but I did
find it in a weird Korean store
yeah hey listen I don't care you can
drink as much as you want
just drive can't just drive responsibly
you're gonna mess of it at least use it
correctly right clone morning I'm going
to be receiving a part in the driveway
now says you can't leave the garage
you're going to have to use some help so
if you just hit the button on the main
six blocks it's the green and blue box
on the Shelf there that's just help you
out even an idiot can figure this one
out
brick oh oh great they don't make them
like they used to probably a good idea
not to order these off of Lorex list I'm
going to need you to order me another
one of these things clone morning head
over the my workbench and I'll activate
my computer remotely using my remote
device Ringo clone war you broke my
computer you really have a delicate
touch I'm gonna fix it the instructions
are you can use some basic actions clone
war you don't let it get to your head
look at that a clone birth portal don't
be afraid just walk through it like that
battery to charge oh don't thank God see
that's a part okay it took you long
enough
listen the part you're holding is of
critical importance you're going to use
it to retrieve an extremely powerful
item but it's not going to be easy it's
going to be one of the hardest things
you've ever done it's going to be very
confusing it's going to be very
difficult it's going to be really
challenging this [ __ ] is about to get
kicked up like a hundred notches and
when you're ready for the point of your
life can you call back on the lower-risk
phone that I did I made for you well
that's all the time you needed to
prepare for your impending doom hey it's
your funeral
alright listen I opened up a new
location for you in the portal
just select the new location with the
arrows on the portal wall lever and then
you know once you've selected it pulled
on pull the lever and a portal will open
up automatically for you you're going to
want to grab the device you but on the
internet you're going to bring that with
you all right clone mori
step one of this very challenging part
of the game
attach the device to the bottom of the
plunger we look you always fill it out
for you the thing goes in the thing you
know I mean it's a pun here where do
plungers usually go looks like a toilets
broken right you're gonna have to see if
you can get it working again
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
yeah Rick thanks thanks a lot for that
you know my mom's alcoholism I can't
wait to get it someday myself three good
job clone morning I told Morty you know
to use the bathtub to deposit that thing
but he insisted on the toilet now we
have to grab it now we have it grab it
head back to the portal
clone Morty you're finally back from
your little bathroom adventure listen I
need to upgrade the car for a very
important outing that I don't want to
get into right now anyways I'm going to
need you to plug the feed into that seat
shaped hole in the engine area mocha
seed artificial intelligence
microprocessor activated
all right good we're going to need some
help upgrading this car since you can't
talk go ahead and call me on your watch
thing you know the thing on your wrist
oh wait a crown trying to help Breck
okay all right you're ready to go huh
all right I'm gonna need your help to
upgrade the rest of the car hey Rick
who's the constable to know how to fix
the car you know I mean it's just a dumb
clone one of the instructions are simple
yeah right Rick you couldn't figure it
out shut up morning so as you can see it
takes a while to figure out the
controller scheme and just figure out
the boundaries so make sure if you're
playing this you play it in a room that
has a big enough space for you to walk
around it so really the big barrier here
is just actually owning the VR gear but
oculus rift any of the competitors it
doesn't really matter they're all about
the same the game itself isn't that
demanding on your hardware and it's not
that expensive it's just that the gear
to play it is expensive but if you do
love Rick and Morty and you do have the
gear I recommend you check it out it's
almost like playing through an episode
of Rick and Morty but it goes on and on
you fix their spaceship then you go on
the adventure so progressively the task
that you perform get harder and harder
like you start out washing laundry you
work your way up to fixing Rick ship
with the seed that comes out of Morty's
but then you go up and you eventually
start fighting the Garoppolo mines so
let me know if you want me to upload
more Rick and Morty VR episodes but
there's a couple more videos that I'll
be posting today so while you guys wait
for that you can click here for all my
rick and morty season 3 and you can
click here for brand-new thor ragnarok
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video
you
[Music]
[Applause]